bonjour merci d'être avec nous ici à
dracy saint loup en saône et loire pour
un nouveau numéro de dimanche en
politique une fois par mois
on sort de nos plateaux pour parler plus
librement des sujets qui font débat est
aujourd'hui au coeur de cette
exploitation nous accueillent patrice et
agnès brocard nous allons nous demander
quel modèle pour l'agriculture un sujet
au coeur de l'actualité avec la
polémique autour du projet de ferme pour
4000 vaut près de digoin ou encore le
bras de fer européens autour de
l'utilisation du glyphosate avec nous
sur ce plateau xavier millot bonjour
vous représenter les agriculteurs bio de
la nièvre membres de bio bourgogne
frédéric brochot bonjour vice président
du conseil département de départementale
de saône et loire chargé de
l'agriculture vous êtes éleveurs
vous-même luc jeanne un bon jour pour
jour vous êtes le secrétaire
départemental de la fdsea de saône et
loire
emily jane un bon jour pas de rapport
entre vous deux élus de la confédération
paysanne vous êtes et le en côte-d'or et
robin ville mène bonjourbonjour
sociologue enseignant chercheur à
agrosup dijon qui forme des ingénieurs
quel modèle donc je le disais alors on a
mis un pluriel on va voir qu'il est
peut-être diplomatique on va en reparler
pour être lapidaire et un poil
provocateur l'agriculture française a
nourri le pays après la guerre à
l'époque on faisait de l'acier on
faisait du charbon faisait des
chaussures on fait plein de choses
aujourd'hui on voit qu'une partie de
notre activité a quitté le pays je pense
à l'industrie
est-ce que l'agriculture d'aujourd'hui
c'est la même
est-ce que elle doit se réorienter vers
quelque chose on parle beaucoup de
produits de luxe en france aujourd'hui
frédéric brochot
commençons par vous qui au conseil
départemental voyez les subventions
l'aide aux agriculteurs
est ce qu'elle est différente eh ce
qu'elle doit aller vers autre chose en
mettant les pieds dans le plat tout de
suite je pense pas il faut pas emmener
notre agriculture réellement à
l'extérieur et au contraire nous ce que
l'on fait au point de vue du département
s'est gardé une très forte proximité
envers notre agriculture et continuer à
l'accompagner
quand vous le savez la loi nôtre est
passée par là l'agriculture en général
tout ce qui est économique repart sur la
région mais nous
dans notre département et je remercie en
plus d'avoir choisi la saône et loire
pour pour cette émission on est quand
même l'un des premiers départements
nationale par rapport à la production
agricole
nous on fait réellement un travail de
proximité d'accompagnement et on a une
agriculture avec différents modèles de
travail d'exploitation et c'est bien
pour cela qu'il faut accompagner chaque
chaque modèle est une niche je dirais et
qu'il faut exploiter accompagner dans la
mutation et pour horreur je dirais
redonné un avantage à notre agriculture
française xavier niel tous les modèles
ont leur place ou où vous vous faites
partie de ceux qui pensent que chercher
plus grands un chercher plus important
c'est une erreur alors je fais partie de
ceux qui pensent que chercher plus grand
c'est pas forcément la bonne solution
par contre effectivement tous les
modèles ont leur place et tout qui a pas
il n'y a pas un système qui est dix fois
meilleur que l'autre
voilà l'agriculture bio amène un certain
nombre de solutions qu'elle partage avec
ce qu'on appelle l'agriculture
conventionnelle
si ça permet de faire avancer les choses
c'est déjà un gros progrès
luc jana à côté vous êtes secrétaire de
la fdsea de saône et loire
est ce qu'aujourd'hui
ces questions se posent je pense à
l'intérieur de votre syndicat par
exemple on sait que on est dans
l'élevage aujourd'hui on va beaucoup
parler d'élevage finalement on sait que
l'organisation des filières c'est
quelque chose de compliqué est ce que il
ya des agriculteurs qui se disent
aujourd'hui est ce que l'eau nos modèles
sont les bons alors déjà je rejoins ce
qu'il ya un dédit différents modèles
existent ils sont complémentaires ils
sont complémentaires et ont toutes leur
leur part dans le schéma aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils répondent à des demandes
différentes et donc il faut est ce que
tout le monde vit avec ses modèles alors
tout le monde vit c'est quoi vivre un
règlement non celle ci s'est dite
correctement aujourd'hui tous les
schémas rond des difficultés à avoir une
pérennité bien sûr mais tous les schémas
tous les schémas parce que il ya des
questions qui se posent de société mais
aussi d'orientation politique avec
l'europe avec les accords de l omc qui
viennent perturber l'équilibré même de
nos choix
voilà on a fait des choix depuis
maintenant une trentaine d'années qui
sont pas toujours pas forcément suivi
par le reste du monde donc ses
équilibres économiques qui sont ici sont
à mettre en en comment a ramené de là il
y en a qu il faut laisser tomber à cause
de ça non je crois pas je crois qu'il
faut il faut réfléchir ensemble avec les
politiques et je crois qu'on n'échappera
pas à un pacte de confiance entre le
producteur l'état les filières il
consommateurs on va y venir aux
consommateurs je vous entends du rire et
mes fils jana quand j'ai posé alors avec
peut-être un peu de malignité la
question est ce que tout le monde vit
dans tous les modèles
c'est pas forcément votre position bah
oui je vais être un peu plus nuancé que
mes collègues qui viennent de parler
c'est à dire que malheureusement est
dans une crise sur moi j'entends
beaucoup de paysans et des éleveurs
notamment qui ont du mal à vivre qui
j'étais à joindre les deux bouts
j'ai assisté aux travaux des haltes et
des ateliers généraux de l'alimentation
et sépare macron à paris au problème
entre ce qu'offre la distribution et les
agro industriels de l'alimentation est
ce que demande le consommateur ça fait
des années que le consommateur trouve a
du mal à se retrouver en tout cas dans
ce qu'on lui propose
et là il va être temps de prendre de
prendre des décisions politiques
après effectivement sur le terrain et à
différents modèles d'agriculture qui se
croisent mais ça n'empêche pas et ça ne
pourra pas ça n'enlève voilà ça peut pas
dédouaner le fait que là on a un moment
crucial et on a besoin d'une politique
agricole et alimentaire forte et ça ça
doit passer par le politique c'est sûr
et à faire un choix si on veut une vraie
politique agricole pour produire
d'alimentation de qualité pour nos
concitoyens pour qu'ils sont en pleine
santé et que les paysans puissent en
vivre
elle vient de dire m les jeunes on est à
un moment charnière
le sociologue que vous êtes qui analyse
la vie du monde agricole et la façon
dont ça évolue et puis vous l'enseigné à
des à des élèves ingénieurs
vous êtes d'accord avec ça on arrive à
quelque chose à un moment donné il ya eu
des évolutions frais de l'après-guerre
en ouverture des missions et là on est à
un autre moment
je pense que l'agriculture s'est
transformé depuis très longtemps depuis
l'après-guerre que
elle continue à se transformer elle
continuera demain il ya eu un article du
professeur bruno lyrique était agrosup
dijon pendant longtemps qu'ils avaient
écrit les agriculteurs dans la fabrique
de l'agriculture elle change aussi parce
que les agriculteurs change
un agriculteur sur deux qui part à la
retraite est remplacé et un sur trois
des personnes qui reprennent des
exploitations ne viennent pas du milieu
agricole les agriculteurs aussi conquis
la reconnaissance de leur statut
professionnel alors qu'ils étaient des
paysans c'était toute une époque années
70 80 jusqu'aux années 90 et il découvre
que manon leur statut n'est pas acquis
qu'ils sont critiqués et que les
systèmes qui nous ont mis en place sont
confrontés à des limites diverses et
donc effectivement il ya elle va
continuer à se transformer il ya
beaucoup d'enjeux beaucoup de directions
la grosse question qui se pose c'est
est-ce le différents modèles qui ont été
évoqués seront
compatible ou pas peuvent coexister ou
est ce une aura qui 30 dominant qui
creuseront les wolofs voilà des indices
c'est ça nous ouvre sur la question
suivante où la suite effectivement parce
que on est ici dans un élevage c'est du
charolais c'est à l'échelle de
l'agriculture mondiale on pourrait
presque dire qu'on est dans du produit
de luxe à côté de beaucoup de choses
donc je reviens à ce que je disais tout
à l'heure c'est quoi vous disiez impact
pour la dimension alimentaire ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que il faut ne
faire que ça ça veut dire qu'on peut
continuer à faire du lait des céréales
pour des choses qui vont être les
produits transformés parce que le grand
public s'en rend pas compte qu'il ya
quand même une part de l'agriculture qui
fait pas ça il en parle avec la turquie
qui produit tout ce qui part dans les
produits transformés qu'on rachète après
en grande distribution
frédéric brochot s'est il va falloir
choisir quand même emily jane à elle
elle vit elle pense qu'il va falloir
choisir ou de toute façon on doit faire
mais l'agriculture
elle est quand même continuellement en
mutation virait et les éleveurs les
agriculteurs en général qu'ils soient
bio qui soit conventionnel comme on le
dit participent à cette mutation
on doit être à l'écouté nous également
mais on doit être à l'écouté du
consommateur
aujourd'hui on se rend compte quand même
et qu'il faut réfléchir irlandais eux
exemple des oeufs en deux ans le marché
des e a été complètement révolutionné
par le fait que les gens ne veulent plus
que d autres les nerfs
et c'est allé très très vite on voit que
les choses vont plus vite qu'elle allait
à une époque
oui et c'est là qu'il faut répondre aux
attentes également du consommateur et
c'est là qu'il faut qu'on accompagne
aussi mais il ya une très forte
communication aussi pour arriver à ces
schémas là mais je pense qu'il faut
quand même être à l'écouté de tous les
producteurs de tous les agriculteurs
pour que cette mutation elle se fasse
j'irai logiquement logiquement et
surtout ce qu'il faut arriver à redonner
et cette mutation se fera encore plus
facilement
on peut faire des états généraux de
l'alimentation
mais s'il n'y a pas un axe et ça je le
demande et avec mon président a carry on
l'a déjà redemander également auprès du
ministre c'est de redonner du revenu à
nos agriculteurs
tant qu'il n'y aura pas de revenus ça ne
changera pas alors on fait comment la
confédération paysanne a demandé puis
s'est félicité ce maquereau a annoncé le
11 octobre dernier à rungis qu il allait
avoir une loi sur le revenu des
producteurs
effectivement si ça passe pas par une
loi nous on pense que ça va être
compliqué que ça vienne directement du
bon vouloir des agro industriels et des
gens qui y tiennent là pour l'industrie
par exemple là j'ai lu vendredi dernier
un communiqué de presse d'une
coopérative céréalière qui annonçait
fièrement deux millions de résultat de
pro l'année passée sauf que enfin moi
personnellement puisque je fais un peu
de polyculture mais tous mes voisins
on revend nos céréales enfin nous les
achète au cours mondial or les
coopératives elles ont acheté les
meuneries elles ont acheté des filières
de boulangerie alors j'ai du mal à
comprendre alors qu'elles sont
structurés qu'elles ont acheté toutes
ces étapes de la chaîne alimentaire
toute la filière il la détiennent
pourquoi on continue à nous l'acheter au
cours mondial et comment il n'y a pas
plus de bruit que ça c'est complètement
indécent qu'une coopérative ose afficher
2 millions de résultats alors que les
producteurs n'ont même pas eu d enfin
voilà ils n'arrivent pas à boucler leurs
pardonnez moi mais vous vous appelez
l'état au secours vous demandez des lois
moi j'ai l'impression que le monde
agricole il il est depuis longtemps
structuré autour de décisions de l'état
et les visions de l'europe via les
décisions du pays
xavier niel vous votre position c'est
aussi ça il faut structurer plus faire
une loi ou ou là le bonheur et ailleurs
où la solution est autrement quand il
faut il faut évidemment structurer
davantage
il faut que le revenu des agriculteurs
puissent augmenter ça c'est une évidence
après chacun chirel à vals faire avec ce
que disait robert il mène tout à l'heure
c'est à dire une nouvelle génération
aussi qui acceptera plus de ne pas
gagner sa vie et de travailler à perte
ah bah non seulement une nouvelle
génération meilleur l'ancienne qui s'en
va oui
il ya des défections en cours de encours
de commandes de travail en fin de
carrière en cours de carrière qui
n'arrivait jamais il ya trente ans en
arrière
mais c'est un vrai problème soit au
niveau de l'école il ya un rapport de
l'insee qui dit que le bio peut être
plus rentable que le conventionnel oui
il ya quelques jours alors je résiste
pas plus qu'on parle de revenus et de
rentabilité
vous partagez ça c'est pas faux c'est
une évidence mais après je dire tout le
monde peut pas être bue en même temps il
faut le temps de structurer les filières
ça va pas se faire du jour le grand
fantasme de tout doit être bio ont fait
doit faire du bio dans toutes les
cantines on doit faire sa part tout
c'est pas si simple que ça c'est ça que
vous ne sais pas si ça mais ça c'est
possible à ce niveau là c'est que ces
cantines louis voilà après avoir du jour
au lendemain 30 ou 50 % de bio
l'agriculture bio ça va pas se faire du
jour au lendemain ça progresse de toute
façon c'est pas par hasard qu'ils
avaient un ferme par jour qui passe en
bio aujourd'hui il ya une réelle demande
je dire l'an dernier les chiffres qui
sont donnés ces 7 milliards de
consommation produits bio
essentiellement la viande les légumes
les produits laitiers et les oeufs quand
on parlait tout de suite c'est pas le
hasard c'est plus un marché de niche
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui se
développe et qui va continuer à se
développer
luc janin revenus des agriculteurs vous
fdsea c'est aussi un de vos axes
nouveaux axes de bataille mais on fait
comment oui alors il est évoqué les
états généraux de l'alimentation
enfin on attache une importance toute
particulière ces travaux pourquoi il ya
deux volets le premier volet qui sait
qu'elle était pas conclut puisqu'il est
toujours en travail mais c'est de dire
de meilleure répartition des marges tout
au long d'une filière voilà parce
qu'aujourd'hui les pères les grands
perdants du schéma actuel c'est à la
fois le producteur et le consommateur
donc il faut il faut absolument et quel
que soit le mode de production qu'on
soit en bio ou conventionnels
si un produit ne répartit pas la marche
tout au long de ces échelons
forcément il y aura des gens qui vont
pas pouvoir suivre le saas est une loi
si une intervention de l'état de votre
point de vue sur ce volet-là sur ce
volet là de toute façon il faut remettre
encadrer les promotions etc
toute chose à faire il ya le deuxième
volet donc le géant de l'alimentation
qui sont sur la qualité sur
l'environnement sur ces choses là et il
ya quand même une contradiction dans
notre pays dans l'europe etc
du fait qu' on choisit un schéma de
production respectueux et dans le même
temps on signe des accords omc avec le
mercosur avec
avec le canada avec des choses comme ça
qui laisse rentrer des produits qui sont
en or mais autant que les nôtres
moi
besson
oui
non
bonjour on vous retrouve on se retrouve
ici à dracy saint loup dans
l'exploitation d'agnès et patrice braut
car on parle des modèles de
l'agriculture et il faut vous le dire il
fait des conditions météos absolument
dans la neige il ya de la pluie le
groupe électrogène a l'air de souffrir
beaucoup dehors donc on espère qu'on va
pouvoir continuer notre discussion
remerciant nos cinq invités quand aussi
défier des conditions météo dantesques
pour venir nous rejoindre à léon on est
il nous reste une dizaine de minutes
d'émission
robin lille mène vous disiez tout à
l'heure nouvelle génération et on
pourrait dire nouvelles conditions dans
lesquelles évolue le monde agricole on
parle d'environnement on parle de
pression des consommateurs on parle de
conditions animales ce qui n'existait
pas non plus avant les étudiants avec
lesquels vous travaillez vous leur
enseigner ça aussi maintenant il va
falloir tenir compte de tout ça bien sûr
alors non je voulais revenir sur ce que
disait monsieur brochet les l'avenir de
l'agriculture
un peut être logique moi je dirais
plutôt qu'il ait négocié et donc les
états généraux de l'alimentation ou les
réunions comme comme aujourd'hui
eh bien ce sont des lieux de discussions
et qu'ils discutent beaucoup
d'agriculteurs des traditions aux
réunions et en même temps l'avenir de
l'agriculture les différents modèles
résulteront aussi des différents
rapports de force qui a dans les
filières ou au niveau des territoires
donc ce n'est pas seulement qu'une
question de logique ou de prendre en
compte des problèmes environnementaux
sanitaires qui sont présents et aussi de
d'exploitation vivable de un rapport
récent montre que les agriculteurs sont
la profession qui se déclare le moins
souvent heureux
5.2 agriculteurs seulement se disent
heureux et on parle beaucoup des taux de
suicide un dans le monde rural qui sont
très importants ce qui est surprenant
c'est que les ouvriers agricoles c'est
30 + 30 % qui sont heureux donc on voit
qu'il ya un poids très lourd sur les
épaules des agriculteurs des
agriculteurs qui se sont restructurées
soit forme d'une profession qui se sont
isolés ils répondent qu'ils sont un plus
50% il se considère comme isolé et donc
il ya aussi tout un
une dynamique alors d'agrandissement
médéric taux de précision mais aussi de
re territorialisation de dialogue et le
dialogue c'est pas que aux états
généraux c'est aussi avec les voisins
dont il ya des pas loin d'ici là harnes
éduquer les cafés paysans qui se met en
place et donc il ya plein de choses qui
se mettent en place et pas que au niveau
de la recherche nature c'est aussi ce
qu'ils agriculteurs en lien avec leur
voisinage en feront aussi c'est ça ça
fait partie aussi des choses à changer
dans le monde rural
c'est un monde très syndiqués monde
agricole avec des structures qui étaient
très fortes qui fonctionnait beaucoup
est ce que on est en train aussi à la
charnière de quelque chose là dedans
avec des choses autre emilie janin est
prêt oui mais lisse c'est un peu en
train de faim les syndicats c'est un
monde très syndiqués mais alors le
l'agrandissement des fermes a quand même
contribuer effectivement à ce que les
paysans et plus en plus de travail donc
de moins en moins de temps pour sortir
donc les pays les syndicats voient comme
leur nombre de cotisants diminué pour
autant
enfin ça dépend mais c'est une tendance
générale tous syndicats confondus
c'est sûr que plus on travaille mais on
a le temps pour sortir mon attend
d'avoir du temps pour sa famille si on
en a eu une parce que beaucoup de
célibat et voilà donc nous c'est clair
qu'on prône une agriculture plus
paysanne enfin l'agriculture paysanne
c'est clairement un projet de la
confédération paysanne et qui s'ancre
sur des terroirs avec des relations
sociales extérieur pour moi
personnellement je suis plutôt heureux
dans ce que je fais mais c'est vrai que
c'est un tabou aussi il ya effectivement
faut faire attention puisque c'est aussi
très tabou de dire dans le monde paysan
je suis heureux dans mon boulot ils
s'étaient culture est le site se dire je
travaille dur je force parce que
attention c'est très mal vu si on se dit
heureux et frédéric brochot sur ce sujet
là nous ce que l'on met sur
l'augmentation de la taille parce que ça
fait plusieurs personnes qui disent la
tendance a été d'augmenter les tailles
et que du coup les gens plus sur le dos
ils sont moins heureux c'est plus
difficile c'est sûr que tu t'en sors on
se rend compte sur notre département que
les exploitations ont augmenté de taille
1 nous
ce que l'on fait pour accompagner et je
dirais pour être plus en lien avec la
société en général on a déjà adhéré le
département agri locales ce qui permet
tout et le éleveurs confondues que ce
soit conventionnel ou bio d'adhérer et
également de rentrer sur le code des
marchés publics pour permettre de
fournir les collèges je salue également
la région adhère depuis quelques mois
quelques semaines à cette base pour les
lycées on va travailler aussi est
consommée gérer locale est également ce
que l'on met en place aussi pour
permettre aux éleveurs à nos
agriculteurs de j'irai sortir un petit
peu de leur exploitation
on va appuyer également notre soutien
sur les services de remplacement qui
puisse avoir des contacts extérieurs à
leur exploitation et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui l'ensemble de nos
agriculteurs ont besoin également de
sortir de leur exploitation
un mot on parlait des pressions
extérieures tout à l'heure c'est on peut
prendre l'exemple du dossier actuel du
glyphosate où tout le monde se l'envoi à
la figure on a du mal à y voir clair
d'ailleurs
mais cette pression aujourd'hui des
consommateurs qui disent par exemple moi
je veux plus produits phytosanitaires et
l monde agricole qui est aussi qu'à
l'habitude de travailler avec cas des
modèles économiques qui s'en servent ces
nouveaux 6 à luc jaguelin de ressentir
cette pression
est ce que vous vous sans vous sentez un
rapport différent avec les consommateurs
aujourd'hui ou pas c'est une nouveauté
une des nouveautés du monde rural ça ou
du monde agricole aujourd'hui pardon
agricole paru alors je mens je pense que
notre principal défaut à nos
agriculteurs c'est pas être des grands
communicants note notre première mission
l'a toujours vu comme produire du mieux
qu'on pouvait par rapport à ce qu'on
nous demandait de faire
par contre la communication nous
échapper c'est pas notre coeur de métier
je pense qu'on a tort je pense qu'il
faut qu'on aille vers le consommateur
pour expliquer nos pratiques
ce qu'on fait et le sujet du glyphosate
en étant d'ailleurs
puisque les pratiques qui sont faites
chez nous tant céréales camp des loges
répondent à des règles pour protéger le
consommateur
alors que dans le même temps ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure des
importations de produits sont réelles
sur nos territoires d'europe et là pas
forcément avec des contrôles de normes
qui sont au même niveau que les nôtres
et les aviculteurs ressentent ça un peu
comme une injustice c'est à dire ils
font des progrès ils recherchent en
permanence le progrès qu'on nous demande
et c'est normal c'est normal par contre
derrière ça par contre derrière ça il ya
de l'importation qui est pas vérifié et
qui permet pas de répondre à vieillot
souriait un peu à côté de vous à ce
moment là t'es pas forcément d'accord
sur en fait c'était quoi c'est sûr on
fait des efforts on fait des progrès
alors c'est vrai que le problème des
importations
on le maîtrise pas du tout après sur le
problème des progrès on a mis en place
quand même il ya sept huit ans un plan
ecophyto qui devait permettre de baisser
de 50% les produits phyto puis on
s'aperçoit au bout du compte qu'on a
quand même augmenter la consommation
donc le glyphosate c'est vraiment
l'exemple type dont on peut parler je
vais aussi c'est quoi ça c'est
l'exigence de production essayer de
garder ses revenus le glyphosate c'est
surtout un problème d'argent
je veux dire s'il n'y avait pas des
intérêts économiques aussi important
derrière on aurait trouvé d'autres
solutions et on a travaillé avant le
glyphosate les agriculteurs existait
avant et puis sont pas morts pour ça
donc voilà à partir du moment où on
laisse les problèmes économiques prendre
la main sur les problèmes techniques et
puis sur la vie des gens ben on arrive à
ces résultats et on l'a eu dans plein
d'autres choses que l'agriculture
il nous reste peu de temps une minute
trente dans cette émission un peu vous
l'avez vu compliquée avec les conditions
météo et les choses comme ça mais c'est
le jeu quand on va un peu quand on a
envie d'aller sur le terrain pour
échanger quelques mots romainville men
vous êtes le sociologue donc vous êtes
le chercheur qui avait une vision sur le
monde
le monde agricole y aura des mais on est
vraiment une charnière ça peut être
notre mot de la fin il va se passer des
choses ou pas or je pense pas être le
seul ici avoir une vision sur
l'agriculture normes et vous êtes un peu
neutre vous êtes un peu quatre casques
bleus
ce qu'on voit ce que d'un côté il ya les
agricultures numérique de précision qui
se développe qui va très bien avec
l'agrandissement des exploitations qui
va très bien avec des firmes agro
industriels qui vont pouvoir fournir sa
des connaissances qui vont être met mise
à l'intérieur des outils techniques et
puis un autre modèle qui se revendique
plus de l'agro écologie qui est où les
connaissances en plus dans les personnes
une connaissance fine des choses et que
ça va plus de paix avec des petites
structures et donc demain est ce qu'il y
aura les deux et donc dans quelle mesure
ces compatibles ou même hybride à bhl et
c'est un peu ces grandes questions qui
se posent actuellement par les questions
des raisons politiques dans quoi
investir
allez ce pur est ce sera le mot de la
fin c'est pas mal de terminer sur cette
question merci à tous les cinq d'avoir
défié les conditions météo pour venir
ici
merci agnès et patrick brocard nous
avoir accueillis dans leurs fermes ici à
dracy saint loup
bon dimanche au revoir et merci
aujourd'hui je mets